hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
I'm the guy who invented curling Dave
Rubin and I've got Jena grad and jimmy
dore with me and let's get right to it
could wave jimmy okay we're gonna start
off walmart so you guys may have heard a
couple weeks ago CBS announced that they
are no longer gonna sell cigarettes even
though cigarettes are legal at least as
of the time that we're taping this and
now seven senate democrats have sent a
letter to walmart CEO Doug McMillon
urging Walmart to stop selling
cigarettes
we rights urge Walmart as the number one
retailer of cigarettes in the country to
stop selling tobacco products in all of
its stores the senator said we recognize
the legality of selling and profiting
from tobacco products however Walmart's
position as the nation's largest
retailer of any kind puts your company
in a unique position to contribute to
the health and well-being of all
Americans ok so I think that's sort of
interesting because tobacco is legal at
the moment and we have this whole thing
with with we'd potentially going legal
across the country to it's slowly
happening so first off before we get
into Walmart CVS has already done this
do you guys back CBS doing this thing
because in a way it could be very bad
business for them because tobacco
products do make a lot of money and
they're super expensive from all the
bitching my friends are doing yeah and
and it's something that if there are a
hundred dollars a pack they're gonna
about it but they're gonna buy it
so it's one of those it's a goldmine and
if you're not selling it that's a pretty
big deal yeah so did you do you think
CVS was right to stop doing it I think I
mean if I can even use this organ to
describe a major company they followed
their heart god bless them if that's
what they want and it makes them look
better roll the dice see if it works but
I think I mean it's gonna take away a
ton of their business people go to
drugstores to buy cigarettes that's why
you go to drugstores to buy condoms and
cigarettes right pretty much following
your heart not something American
companies often he did often do what do
you think I'll take a CVS got rid of
cigarettes and they've already lost that
smoky bohemian vibe they used to have
in there it really was but so then
they're do it for health reasons and
that's why I rights why I think it's
still nice that Walmart is gonna get rid
of cigarettes but they're still gonna
sell Scotch guns and ammo and Larry the
Cable Guy CDs which were very bad for
your okay so they're getting rid of the
tea but what about the a and the F yeah
with the you know I mean they they sell
you know just jugs of moonshine or
whatever and and I'm down I'm supported
and and shotguns and you can get like
buckshot that already seasoned with like
barbecue or mesquite so when it goes
into the animal it's already ready to go
yeah but you can't get a Marlboro light
yeah do you guys think that there could
be an actual economic benefit from them
because people might I've read people
saying well we would go out of our way
now to go to CVS let's say because
they're they're not supporting tobacco
so we'll go a little further if that
means we have to pass by a courier or
something else to be perfectly honest as
a nonsmoker I couldn't even if you told
me right now and this wasn't in the news
which drug stores sell cigarettes I
wouldn't be able to tell you yeah so
well it's pretty much everybody but CVS
yeah and I wouldn't have known that yeah
so because CVS is making a big deal
about it I'd say I think everyone but
that one that everyone's talking about I
don't know Walgreens know nobody knows
nobody cares and I've been going to CBS
even before this because I enjoy
customer service and that's why I like
to stand in line to be treated rudely
and not be able to find the things I
want but I like the idea that you're
talking about your friends complaining
about how expensive cigarettes and I
agree when I smoke days to smoke
generics cuz I wanted cancer but I
wanted full price it's you know I want
to deal on my emphysema that's what I'm
looking for and I spoke the lights too
right cuz I was yeah I was also a health
nut yes did the money stop you from
smoking it and it was it all health or
was it because the taxes especially how
much your cigarettes here I'm not even
sure I think it's maybe I don't know
California's like eight bucks a pack but
in New York I think it's like 16 or so I
was in the casino in Atlantic City the
Borgata yeah been there and so I I
remember I was starting to smoke again I
was going back making one of those bad
adult decisions and ten dollars the guy
wanted for a pack of cigarettes I was
like ten dollars
give me those
so but I don't smoke so I haven't smoked
in years so thank God yeah do you guys
think there's a risk in companies like
Walmart CVS not selling things that are
perfectly legal because then won't it
drive the price up of cigarettes
actually you can't get it at Walmart
which is supposed to be cheap and you
can't get it at CVS well then just these
little places are gonna be selling it
and they're just gonna be jacking up the
price is even higher or is that the
endgame because then no one will be able
to employ it I think this is one of the
things that I'm gonna predict you're
gonna say something to the effect of Oh
Gina if you were any closer I'd pat you
on the head but aren't you not allowed
to do that aren't you supposed to not do
that do what like drive prices up just
because stuff is hard to get well a
company they can if they can't release
it all over the place then it naturally
is gonna cause price to go yeah yeah so
do you want me to pay you on there now
no I don't know that was the break that
I shouldn't yeah what do you think so my
enemy I give us a little economic
breakdown here if legal substances
aren't being sold by the bail charge 50
bucks a pack just because you can't get
them at CVS that's what I'm saying but
the demand will increase as the supply
goes down Dave I don't I took about 101
I don't know much about economics but I
do know that the price of tobacco is
very inelastic and so what that means is
that I don't know what it means but the
point is cigarettes are gonna be cheaper
and more expensive at the same time well
you've really given me something to
think about final thought oh this will
all be okay when weed is in Walmart and
CVS right that's right it is in my
health food it is a health food you know
that gives you moobs you and you know it
carefully carrots cured my cancer please
god bless I mean I never had it but I
never got it either so there you go
there it's a pre cure believe me if if
we'd gave man boobs bit Jimmy would be
like a Triple D right now okay all right
let's move on Apple have you heard about
these guys it's apparently a big phone
computer company little guys I think I
think they're gonna be doing okay there
is a rumor that they are thinking about
buying Tesla Tesla if you don't know
they make electric cars and components
for electric cars it's an American
company and their CEO Elon Musk met with
Apple executives and now the tech
bloggers are all freaking out thinking
whoa is Apple gonna start making the AI
car if you don't know about the Tesla
look at a couple of them these are
pretty fancy things these things have
been popping up all over LA have you
guys been yeah that's the DeLorean door
right you've driven in one I've driven
in one and how do you feel they are
amazing four so reversed of all the
plastic so you step on the pedal and bam
it's just like you just don't like it's
a rocket or something yes their
navigation stream a screen is like as
big as my television which is nice
because the navigation screen I have in
my Prius you can't even read the names
of the streets this you can see the
names of every it's great I love a Tesla
yeah okay so I'm pretty sure we're all
on board the idea of the electric car
right we're good to go with that
sustainable environmentally friendly etc
is this just the next step for Apple
like doesn't this just seem pretty
obvious like they've dominated
everything that we have in our pockets
and now they're gonna dominate what we
takes over Tesla then there's one thing
that we can guarantee that if it's not
already Tesla will become a super shitty
product that will be super way more
expensive than it already is and if
anything breaks on it you have to
replace the whole car yeah that's that's
what I can guarantee you about Tesla
being owned by we're gonna have to take
our Tesla's into that genius bar with
your smug 18 year old baby made in China
anyway the idea of that my car is the
manufacturing of my car is making
someone want to commit suicide it's a
good feeling inside like a somebody's
really had a shitty time putting this
together right but it'll continue to be
designed in Cupertino because that's
what they always say in the Apple
commercials right designed in Cupertino
they somehow don't mention made in China
no and that's the only as as though all
of the exotic locales in the entire
world that I would want to know the
weather on my phone the only one that it
comes with is Cupertino which I had to
find on a map when I got an Apple phone
right because they want you to think
that's like Mecca or Jerusalem or
something like that beautiful downtown
Cupertino I've stayed in beautiful
downtown Cupertino at the I forget the
name of the or the Grand View Inn did
you drive your Tesla there I wish I
drove my Tesla there I drove my Prius
there right Prius so you're halfway
there right just to give you a little
sense of the numbers Tesla is worth
twenty four billion dollars
people's worth yeah small paltry 485
billion so yes they could easily afford
to make this thing happen
but let's get away from that the
specifics of that a little bit just
electric cars
why haven't they picked up is this just
101 you know the car lobby keeping the
electric people t-rex's and
stegosauruses are sitting around and
saying we have to protect this fossil
fuel and they're smoking their stogies
and they don't want that to happen yeah
so it's just standard money there's no
doubt about it I mean look what they did
to the even American politicians will
on American cars look what they did
to the Chevy Volt right so or at least
and the but they came out and they were
like oh this is they really poo-pooed it
yeah and even though it was the car of
the year and all that stuff and so it to
the point where it didn't Chevy take it
off the market for a little while or
they did some well there were some
recalls and then it's it's back on now
and future obviously is electric cars I
think but you know all the oil in the
ground I mean you have to understand
that the most powerful richest
corporations that the world has ever
known own that oil and they're not going
to leave it there so it's coming out
you're kidding right unlike the
cigarette thing that we just did where
they maybe were doing it out of the
goodness of their hearts you're thinking
that the oil people we're not gonna do
that's coming out so I really don't see
and this whole thing about oh now we're
getting sino one chance on the subject a
little bit but they're saying now old
we're gonna get serious about climate
change the president's getting serious
about it's too late it's over climate
change is happening it's going to keep
happening and we need to put our
energies into living with climate change
not trying to stop it or change it
because it's a tool on your crazy
tangents so if Tesla is going to be
bought by Apple isn't this the type of
thing that could be about how do we live
yet climate change because if anyone can
give us products that will believe in
and all that it is no go Gina because
Apple kills people the the conditions in
which the Apple products are made are
shitty and they're made in third world
countries and it's super polluting and
it sucks and nobody can afford a Tesla
and so nobody's going to drive them
so none of this is gonna matter anyway
it's all for PR and it's all just for
looks so it's easy to crap on Apple but
should we maybe give them a little props
that maybe this could be good you're not
on board the crazy train I think I don't
I don't think anyone who it would matter
so you could afford it yeah I don't know
by the way it cost about 70,000 bucks
they started about 70 pounds great Grey
Poupon windows by the way you don't even
grab the button windows with its up I
might sell on my dream board right next
to a new bathroom because one bathroom
really taught in a marriage helicopters
hovering over my home alright let's move
on let's talk about yoga mats and fast
food because yeah there's a chemical
that is in yoga mats that of course is
in your fast food you thought it was all
pink slime but no it's it's even worse
it somehow managed to put farts and
you're okay patience Jimmy you'll see in
just a moment it's called a Zoda carbon
ID I think I got that close to correct
will give me the correct pronunciation
down below and it is in a ton of fast
food Subway announced last week they're
not gonna use it in their bread anymore
that's for the six inch or the footlong
but we've got a list of other companies
that are using it this includes
McDonald's chick-fil-a Burger King
Dunkin Donuts Wendy's Arby's
jack-in-the-box Carl's jr. Hardee's and
White Castle basically the reason Subway
is dropping it is because there was an
online petition which garnered about
80,000 signatures this substance is
already banned in Europe really yes the
Center for science and public interests
want it banned completely here in the
United States but of course that isn't
happening and we're so far leaving it up
to these companies all of those still
have it Subway's getting rid of it
should this just not surprise us well
every time we do these stories on pink
slime and literally they're the reason
they use it is because it makes the
bread more elastic and spongy er like a
yoga mat so it's literally downward dog
right on your sandwich yeah yeah what is
going on in this country with this kind
of stuff we're used to it I mean I have
friends that come here from other
countries get super fat in like two
weeks and like slow down turned gray and
we're just used to it we don't know what
the
as we know what their problem is I
haven't eaten that in a while and I
had like some McDonald's and I honestly
couldn't eat the bread because of the
sponge factor it freaked me out and now
I know why yeah it literally is a sponge
it's it's it's literally a sponge and if
you're into it it we've been eating
this stuff since we were kids it's
mature it's all you know it's it's it's
in our it's it's in who we are its it's
bound to our DNA it's not gonna matter
at this point but if it grosses you out
but for the love of God stop eating it
what does this chemical actually do does
it until your body doesn't cause cancer
or maybe a heart problem maybe memory
loss Dave well Jimmy good question
because some researchers think it causes
cancer so yeah this is the stuff we're
putting in our body and I think you're
right we've just done this stuff for so
long that you see the pink slime video
and you're like you find out yoga mats
are in your buns and you go like you're
eating this and it's all made of
plastic and you're eating it you're
consuming it you're putting it in your
stomach you can't even breathe it's
probably blurring your vision it's your
it's making you fat it's making you
obese and you're like oh CBS doesn't
have cigarettes okay like none of this
like what does it matter I'm
feeling sort of nihilistic but what is
it what does any of this matter
because we're not gonna stop eating it
anyway go down a dark hole deep fried
like pop tops from milk jugs we'll eat
anything as long as you stick it in the
fryer isn't it our right as Americans to
eat crap and suffer the consequences
later or as that commercial with
what's-his-name the plumber the Cable
Guy yeah I eat corn dogs all day long
and they not take pepcid like isn't that
our right as Americans to be fat
who are unhealthy and eating car you
know eating plastic and isn't that what
America is all about
you know as Chris Christie said mistakes
were made anyway yes it is our right to
eat there's it's funny you talked about
how that chemical is already banned in
Europe there's lots of stuff that's
already been out Europe but it's because
the corporations that have much more
control of the government in America
than they do in Europe that we have to
eat Franken food as a one judge called
Chicken McNugget Nuggets right half of
its foam matchstick and the
other half is chicken knuckles no I mean
you guys see there's a video on YouTube
now where McDonald's in Canada did a
thing about a three-minute video we'll
link to it here where they said people
think we use pink sign but we don't and
then they show you the actual process
and I assure you the process ain't
pretty either it's just great yeah it's
not pink it's great so that's thing and
and like you said do we have the right
to beef at Fox totally but I think we
also have the right to know what's
causing us to beef at Fox yeah if it's
just you know high cholesterol good
old-fashioned butter and lard hey knock
yourself out but if we're eating yoga
mats we should have the right to know
that we're eating out okay so if we
don't have the right to be fat folks in
America there's a lot of people at risk
of being arrested right now that's all
I'm saying and have mass incarceration
and I mean max man we're gonna underline
the math all right so last thought on
this joking aside though is the real
issue here that we are just so separated
from our food like bi you know people
used to have land and grow their food
and you know you want some vegetables
we'll go pick them you want some grapes
go pick them and now our food is so
separate from us we don't know what the
hell is going on is there any way to
reverse that process you know since my I
was I'm a big Italian food person and so
my I used to date this girl who had
family there I'm gonna go visit they
would like you visit their family they
go they go kill a chicken we come in
they get so yes it was it was right
there so you were connected to the food
you were connect now it comes into that
make you crazy like oh god I can't look
no I thought I wasn't that need look at
that and it actually tastes better to
the horse it does because a lot of
people will say like I'm sorry I can't
eat anything with bones in it and like
what did you just say like they're
eating all this crazy but they
don't want you're absolutely right they
don't want to be connected to it they
don't want any part of it and they're
very happy to be like that
and speaking of bones correct me if I'm
wrong but I'm pretty sure they're
allowed to put in a certain percentage
of bone in McDonald's beef so yeah
you're not getting away from the bones
that easy Capital One sent out a
contract update to all the people that
have their credit cards and in it it's
said basically that they can now drop by
your house unannounced so here these are
literal these are actual quotes we're
not making this up we may contact you in
any manner
we choose and that includes showing up
yes such contacts can include calls
email text faxes or a personal visit
these personal visits can be at your
home and at your place of employment we
may modify or suppress caller ID and
similar services and identify ourselves
on these services in any manner we
choose meaning we can fake the phone
number that we're dialing from and then
pretend we're somebody else we can also
show up by your house
blah blah blah now a lot of people have
already said well this is a violation of
the Fourth Amendment that's not quite
true because the the Fourth Amendment is
about the government you know search and
seizure so obviously Capital One and
credit card companies are not the
government yet but it's getting pretty
close
is this just absurd I think it's
okay if they show up at your house in a
white shirt a black tie and ask you if
you heard the good news about Capital
One yeah like we've increased your
credit line and you don't have to pay
off your debt I'm used to this because I
get my visa through the NSA and so I've
been used to this life this is Corey
audits is unbelievable and what is where
do they want to come to my place of
employment for because I have a credit
card it's like well I think this is all
about scaring you so that if you get
into debt and then in the old days when
they could just make phone calls well I
think they want you to fear that they're
gonna literally show up at your house
you can already haunt you forever you
can't get rid of your credit card debt
anymore because they rerigged the rules
so I don't understand so this is just
more fierce is just more fear and the
fact that they're saying this is what
we're gonna do with the phone calls to
we're gonna pretend to be someone else
there'll be actual visit God's showing
up the toiler yeah okay so I think so no
I don't like alec baldwin anymore now
because of this - yeah he say what did
you call him at farts music he's a
fart snorkel yeah yeah you
didn't think you were gonna get to use
that joke anymore did you did it there
you go that was a little time for Jimmy
you're up but really like how much of
this also is just that these freaking
things that we sign you know that you
immediately just click accept accept and
you look we do this with iTunes just as
easily we do it with credit cards how
much of it is just that you don't have a
lawyer on retainer sitting next to you
all the time when you're about to sign
up for something
certainly when I'm on Facebook I do that
is a that is really scary you know
because if you don't realize it when you
leave Facebook and you go to another
website there's you don't sign out from
Facebook Facebook's gathering all your
data so when you go back to Facebook
you're like oh my god there's a ad for
penis enlargers I thought what am i
doing you know that has nothing to do
with what I was doing on Facebook
nothing to do why is that happening
yeah so well it was because I was
looking for black hookers and they knew
I was like Google Chrome incognito what
is it really yeah even if I put on
private browsing that still goes back to
Facebook no I don't know we don't know
we're not even way I thought pretty sure
we're all agreed it goes to the NSA so
yeah so forget about Facebook but really
this thing with the with the pages and
page a thing you can't have a lawyer
with you all the time and even if you
were a lawyer are you going to read
everywhere nobody that's whatever so
what is the point of that even could
that hold up in court well he did check
the I agree things with iTunes and if
you try I tried to be a good citizen I
tried to edits so many words that I've
never heard of in an order I've never
seen them that I'm already ruined before
I get through the first sentence yeah so
is this just the next step in how we've
watched our privacy erode I've been
right between the NSA and what we know
is going on with Facebook and everything
else but sure now not only do you know
where we are and we have GPS and we've
given you all our information but also
show up at my house well you want lunch
can I get you a lot I mean really is
that is that the next step like it's
just been systemic erosion well this is
all why not it's actually worse than
1984 it's worse than the TV screen that
can see you because they can see you
when you leave the TV screen they see
you everywhere you go no matter where
you are they know where you are what
you're doing who you had dinner with who
you exact who you're cavorting with they
know more stuff from their metadata than
they do if they were actually listening
you actually to that point you actually
it's actually worse than that I think
too you know why they know what we had
for dinner and who you're with because
they've armed us with Lee with the
weapons to police ourselves yes and so
it's not about you know like Big Brother
it's about here this is really fun and
slides the cameras over to us and gets
us hooked on it gets me hooked on it
Google glass that now they're talking
about don't be a glass hole and
and and take people when they don't know
it and all this but we're having
fun with it too we don't really have
room to talk yes so they give us
snapchat people send all these pictures
thinking they're you know gonna
disappear in six seconds
yeah then of course we find out last
week that snapchats been compromised not
only within snapchat itself but within
your entire phone you had to be a 14
year old girl and I am so glad I'm not
one yeah oh my god
nobody's ever heard of just taking a
screenshot of some poor child I've never
been 14 year old boys a little bit
harder okay let's move on Jimmy I don't
know how you're gonna feel about this
story because according to millionaire
match calm which is an online dating
service for millionaires they did a
survey and it turns out that rich women
prefer conservative men nearly 77
percent of Democratic female
millionaires said they would prefer to
date a conservative man eighty one point
four percent of female millionaires
prefer a conservative man rather than
someone liberal this includes
Republicans Democrats and independents
only ten percent of female millionaires
said they prefer to date a liberal man
and of the women surveyed 85 percent
agreed that conservative men are better
in bed Wow you know we do all work here
at a progressive liberal network you
little nanny boy you are you shocked
that rich women don't want to be with
you Jimmy do I want I want to apologize
to those 85 percent of women who think
that's conservative men are better at
that I got married and I can't prove
them wrong yeah but you'll get out there
in the field because yes yes and up to
you to talk about I would say also take
care of the labia minor with them but
the point is yes you know it's all about
it goes back to our reptilian brain
right what men want what women want what
we want sexually and romantically has
been engineered genetically for us for a
couple million years right so we we
don't really you think you're choosing a
partner based on your conscious thoughts
but the truth is we're choosing our
sexual partners on our unconscious
thoughts so that I think that's why even
liberal women want a quote unquote
they think to be a conservative man
women want older men more secure men men
want younger women who are more fertile
it's all about procreation and that's
what this is about but they're wrong
about that liberal men can be just as
drunk look at me look at this guy you
have you see the hair on his chest up
look at my god I have something to say
about that yes I think it's much simpler
than that I think that rich rich women
want conservative guys because they
don't want some pool boy spending all
their money I don't think it's that I
don't think it's that complicated they
don't want you know kato living off
their and just and just blowing
through all their money conservative men
won't do that okay and kato kaelin
famous liberal I don't know so I don't
know I don't know if he's I don't think
he's anything the idea of just like you
know some like three spirit anybody but
like free spirit man and I'll take care
of you baby or whatever they want to
keep what they have so they might as
well be with somebody who's fiscally
conservative yeah I wouldn't know I'm
broke but but I get the idea of it right
I think a lot of you know women if
they're given the choice between say
Andrew Breitbart or Matt Damon they
might go Matt Damon first off Andrew
Breitbart did so yes most a man want to
sleep with a live man that you in a
millionaire Hollywood let's go George
Will or Ben Affleck that's a good one
when I go Ben Affleck on there yeah oh
no doubt yes well how much is this do
you guys think has something to do with
just that liberals because liberals are
for gay rights and women's rights it
makes liberals seem ish and a
woman maybe wouldn't want to be with a
issue it's just like women don't
want you to ask what to do in bed right
even though they even sex therapists
tell you you're supposed well it's been
my experience that women like a man who
takes control it goes back to that whole
thing you know if we can't get out of
our sex roles we have them for a reason
and so women like that a man who's in
control if you ask hey can I do that
states to blows the mood and so
you know you can talk before or you can
talk after but during you have to
the man right so getting past the
intellectual I'm gonna let you go but
getting past the intellectual part of
boots you know being for obviously
women's equality and gay equality do you
think there might be something about a
guy who just believes what he believes
on that diner doesn't care about it that
you might find attractive I guess I mean
I I tend to attract people in my life I
think in general that believe the
opposite of what I believe because I
think it's more interesting I don't need
a bunch of people who I agree with
hanging out and giving the thumbs-up to
each other but the reason why I think my
first comment about this whole subject
was about the money was because that was
the first thing that made sense to me I
don't personally understand where these
statistics come from I think they are
100 percent raw millionaire match that
is that though if you're a millionaire
and you have to put a millionaire mascot
yeah you get on a freaking your own
private jet and don't find somebody like
if anyone needs a note pad in my humble
opinion because I don't have too many
things I'm certain about in this world
that would be the time to grab it okay
there is nothing more irritating than a
man that's it there is nothing more
irritating than a man who says you know
what I don't even need you to tell me
what you're into what you like what you
do because I got this all under control
I got like you know what you don't have
anything under control there's 51% of
the population that you have not
serviced in any way you don't know
anything about them so lose your number
you know what Gina yeah
don't worry about it cuz I'm gonna bring
us over to the last segment that's right
let's talk about the internet trolls we
haven't talked about them for a while
you know a lot of sites have been slowly
banning the anonymous comments YouTube
as you guys know I'm sure has been
changing their comments a lot of
comments are disappearing and getting
spammed all that kind of stuff the
Huffington Post has said they're gonna
ban anonymous comments although that
hasn't happened yet but an interesting
study came out on the trolls researchers
at the University of Manitoba
investigated whether people who engage
in trolling are characterized by
personality traits that fall into the
so-called dark tetrad Machiavellianism
which is a willingness to many
callate and deceive others narcissism
which is egotism and self-obsession and
psychopathy which is the lack of remorse
and empathy and finally sadism which is
the pleasure in the suffering of others
so the study found that these traits and
sometimes a combination of these traits
are something that the trolls as they
were I really wish there was a better
word for that seem to all or most have
Jimmy take it away what no is that a
study about those personality traits of
internet trolls or Catholic school
teachers because that's what it seemed
like that every Catholic school teacher
I had suffered from all of those things
it's a fine line it's a fine line yeah
you know what the thing about we are in
an increasingly impolite society right
it's brutal if you go to go to YouTube
pick any video you look at the fourth
comment or the fourth commenter always
burst lessly rips the third commenter
and then the fifth comment urges right
the peacemaker tries to find common
ground and for that he's rewarded by the
six commenter impugning his sexuality
there's basically like a decent
conversation for a little bit and then
it devolves into just everyone attacking
each other but is there some of you
knows I know it's easy to make fun of
the curls and we do it all the time but
is there something healthy about it is
there something healthy about the
ability to anonymously just vent and
then you can still do this outward
normal life but that you get that
out yeah no okay because I don't think
that's what trolling is and by the way I
think it's a perfect word because I
think in this time were we're also
politically correct and sensitive this
we can finally call something what it is
this hate speech by these people that
don't feel they have any other power or
any other outlet and any other way I
think it's a perfect word for it and if
it wasn't if it had a point and if it
was constructive it wouldn't be called
trolling so I don't know what the
healthy benefit of that is yeah and
maybe and that's why I don't I
do not read comments because I really
truly believe that if you like me or
hate me it really is none of my business
if I got rid of all the death threats
and rape fantasies and all of the
marriage proposals I would just go back
to me yeah so
doesn't matter I know how big my boobs
are I was born with them
I get it I know you know I'm so glad you
like them but I don't need you to tell
me about them so I I get it and I just
don't really see what the benefit is of
going on logging in burning calories to
actually do the work but I don't know
who's going on reading them either when
it comes to that could you get as a
comedian oh you find that you can get 20
good compliments and you're like a
Zippity do that but you get one bad line
my undercover name I have several you
have sir and you're responding to these
people and fighting with them you know
it's sometimes does that mean you have
these traits I think I might have some
of them I think the one positive thing
that trolls do when it's you know you'll
see a guy and he'll write something and
then you're like oh and then I like I'll
catch mice oh he's he's goofing around
right this guy's just trying to get a
reaction and then it helps me take a
step back and see it as for okay so I'm
not too emotional I don't get it helps
me put actually does help me pull back
and kind of deal with these things in a
more rational way actually the whole
commenting or the whole idea of whatever
video I'm watching yeah so neither one
of you as the freedom lovers that I know
you are you don't want to get rid of
them them so despite everything you just
said you don't you think that it's a
perfectly fine thing to exist right I
just don't understand and and maybe it's
because it's too personal for me but I
don't understand how you are allowed to
do stuff like this anonymously I've
never understood that
that I don't get right so please take it
away if you understand it well what do
you think about it I mean people clearly
wouldn't do it right if it wasn't
anonymous so do you think YouTube should
should ban the anonymity uh-huh you know
that's tough III you know this new thing
that they've done were yet with the
Google+ and though I hate it yeah and it
you know it's it's actually driven some
people away from YouTube so I think it's
bad I think you just got to let people
who gives a if you know who the
person is don't you know it's just a
comment this pass over it you don't
think that that holds the person doing
it accountable it doesn't give them
another layer of maybe
not that really that guy because for me
I've never really been one I can handle
myself I don't care it doesn't matter to
me and this has always been my problem
it's my poor mother it's my Porfiry
these people are proud of me they want
the best for me they don't need to go to
their you know little organizations or
their bank or whatever and go look at
what my daughter's done google her name
and see like something horrible you know
that I can handle myself but I don't
want to put people who love me and who
are much sweeter than me through that
that's actually really funny there is a
guy who commented on a lot of our early
videos who used his avatar was a picture
of Bill O'Reilly and I think it said
like you know Bill O'Reilly 69 or
something and my mom called me and she
said Bill O'Reilly's been writing these
crazy sounds like but you got it yeah
and I said mom not you know sometimes
they fake you know but yeah you you need
so you wouldn't ban them you'd let him
be no I do what I like is kind of made
me I don't know why made me think it so
Jimmy but like my you know you're my
mother no matter what they just don't
understand like your mom didn't
understand that's not Bill O'Reilly yeah
like I remember when my uh my second
Comedy Central special aired and my mom
and I was like hey mom would really did
well it's about she's like oh great
hopefully somebody will see this and
give you a break like this is the
goddamn break I have a whole hour on
television they're giving me my whole
hour to say whatever the I want
it's a big deal it worked out all worked
out somebody did see me and they gave me
a goddamn TV job there you go people we
are ending this with a shout-out to
Jimmy's number-one Kroll his mother
that's that's really pretty great thank
you guys for watching don't forget to
subscribe down below
jeanna grad jimmy dore their Twitter
errors are right there and we'll do it
again next week thank you